I promise that you'll never find another
like me it's a new era for Taylor Swift
the queen of cryptic clues covers the
music issue of Entertainment Weekly and
we're already dissecting the Flair on
her denim jacket everything from cats to
a gravestone that says I tried two
references of TV shows like Game of
Thrones Grey's Anatomy and Friends but
those Selena Gomez Troye Sivan and Dixie
Chicks nods have us wondering upcoming
collapse in her first interview in three
years
Taylor talks about her infamous Easter
eggs saying quote Easter eggs can be
left on clothing or jewelry this is one
of my favorite ways to do this because
you wear something that foreshadows
something else I just have a great time
with these things fans had a great time
sifting through Taylor's Instagram posts
starting in late February with the
notorious 7 palm trees post turns out
the photo was shared the day Swift
finished her seventh album quote those
Easter eggs were just trying to
establish that tone which I foreshadowed
ages ago in a Spotify vertical video for
delicate by painting my nails those
pastel colors
into your eyes
Oh
[Music]
one big clue Swift confirms is that her
new album will feature more songs than
any of her previous releases she's
trying to convey an emotional spectrum
with happy songs Bob's and really really
really really sad songs but not enough
to where you need to worry about me we
just trying to get past something and
understand something I'm going through
by writing about reflecting on the
darker reputation era I don't like your
little game Swift atributes her loving
fans especially those on tour for the
tonal shift going into ts7
that is such a beautiful